Hi Data2100 students, now
that you've learned more about
aggregate functions and you're
familiar with max, min, average,
sum, and count, I want to introduce
you to the group by clause.
So again, we're using structured
query language and we're introducing
another clause, like select
and from, but it's called the
group by clause. So let's go ahead
and take a look at this clause.
So my question with
group by clause is how
do we make aggregate
functions more useful?
So if I was to say, return
the number of overland guests,
you could say, all right,
I can count the guest IDs.
So I would say, select count
guest ID from guest table. But now
I want you to show me the number
of guests per education level.
Hmm, okay, so let's think about
this. So I'm gonna come over here.
I'm going to grab this information.
so i'm going to actually those
are my examples i have downloaded
for you so i'm going to create a
new query sheet so let's answer
the question that we were just
given so the number of guests okay
number of guests per education
level well according to my overland
erd and data dictionary i know
that we are going to be using
that guest table right so here's
my guest table and i'm going to
count the number of guests in
my guest table so let's go ahead
and just do a quick select count
I'm going to count the guest ID
and I'll say from guest. Okay,
now hopefully you're recognizing
what is going to run here. This
is going to count the number of
records, right? But it's going to
give me a null as the column name
as I haven't given it an alias.
So instead of, so I'm going to
say select count guest ID as,
and I'll say num of guests. Okay,
so select count guest ID as num of
guests. Now when I run this, I can
see here that I have 13,140 guests
as my total number of guests. But
now it wants to say per education
level. Hmm. Okay, so I have, right
now I'm counting all of my records.
But now what I want to see is number
of guests per education level. So
if I look back at my Overland ERD
and Data Dictionary, I can see
here that I have this edu field. So
that's what I'm going to use here
in my select clause. So we can say
select edu, count guest id is number
of guests. Now if I am to run this,
what we'll notice is column guest
id is invalid in the select list
because it is not contained in
either an aggregate function or the
group by clause. So this error is
really helpful in understanding
what's going on here. So again,
guest, so it's just saying guest.edu,
this means the edu field in the
guest table is invalid in the select
list because it's not contained
in either an aggregate function or
the group by clause. Okay, so when
I have an aggregated field here,
so I'm counting the guest ID,
and a non-aggregated field, which
would be EDU, okay, so when I
have an aggregated field and a non
-aggregated field, then I need, I must
group by the non-aggregated field,
okay? So now when I go ahead and
run this, I can see here that I
have the different education levels
and their number of guests. So now
I can say, hey, I have 209 guests
who have a high school education
level, 3,424 guests that have a
bachelor's degree education level.
So now I am breaking apart, if you
will, that total number of guests,
right, that count, and now I'm breaking
it apart into groups by education
level. So historically, when I
have just aggregated all the fields
together, right, counting to guest
IDs. I'm just basically taking all the
rows and coming up with one value to
represent, in this case, the number
of guests. But now what I'm doing
is I am grouping that big value into
smaller groups, right? I'm saying
group by now education level. So
now all that's being returned to me
here are groups, right? So I have a
group of high school education level
that has 209 guests in that group.
Bachelor's degree, 3,424 guests
in that group. So now what's
being returned to me is
groups, right? And looking at
the education level and the
number of guests. So this helps
me make aggregate functions
significantly more powerful.
All right, so let's see where this
falls into play here, right? So we
have select column names from table
names where conditional expression
group by that's my aggregate function
helper having is conditional for
groups and then order by and i sort
the output okay so this is probably
the most difficult portion of our
sql module again we're just talking
about group by here we're going to
introduce having in just a minute but
if there is an aggregated field and
a non-aggregated field in the select
clause always group by the non
-aggregated field okay i would write
that down So if there's an aggregated
field like count guest ID and a non
-aggregated field, meaning there's no
count, sum, max, min that is being
performed on like this education
level, right? This is not being
aggregated. It doesn't have a count.
It doesn't have a max. It doesn't have
a min. We're just selecting that field
on its own. So it's non-aggregated
in the select clause. We always
group by the non-aggregated field.
Okay, perfect.
All right. So I like to think
of this in terms of Starbursts.
Why do I like to think
about this in terms of
Starbursts? Well, I love
Starbursts. Starbursts over like
melting a Starburst over
a campfire. Oh, so good.
So I really love Starbursts.
And I created a mini
database table. You
probably guessed it at
this point. You're like,
yeah, Reagan, you would.
So here I have a mini database
table. So I just select Star from
Starbursts. You don't have access to
this. I know it's a very, you know,
confidential table here. I'm just
kidding. But what I did is I created a
Starburst table based upon bags of
Starbursts that I received. So I had,
so I went in, I had a bag of
Starbursts. I pulled one Starburst out,
gave it Starburst ID number one and
labeled it. It was a pink Starburst.
Starburst ID number two, it's a
yellow Starburst, red Starburst,
orange Starburst. You get the vibe,
right? Well, everybody generally,
but most people have a favorite
Starburst that they enjoy. I personally
love a pink starburst. Oh, so
good. So I want to know how many
starbursts do I have of
each color? Okay, that's my
foundational question. How many
starbursts do I have of each
color? So let's take a look here.
So if I just did select star
from starburst, I am just
right showing all my rows, all
my columns. So now let's do
a select count starburst ID.
All right. And then
what I want to do, and
I'm going to say as a num of Starburst.
Okay. So let's see here.
So I have a hundred,
how convenient. I have
a hundred Starburst.
All right. So what's your favorite
Starburst color? Is it orange,
yellow, red, pink? I know there's
other varieties, but let's
just stay with that. So let's
see which of which bag, right,
so I have a big bag here, I
pulled out all these Starbursts.
Which, what one of you that likes
pink Starburst, orange Starburst,
red Starburst, really wants that
bag based upon it having more
of one color of Starburst. So
let's take a look here. So I'm now
going to select color. Now a little
pop quiz here, will this run?
I hope you said no, Reagan, it
will not run because you have an
aggregated function, or an aggregated
field and a non-aggregated field.
Therefore, we must, we know that
we must group by the non-aggregated
field. Okay. So now I'm going to
go ahead and run this and I can
see here, oh, I have some missing
data. So I have some null values.
So, um, this is just saying that
this is empty. Null means empty.
Okay. That I, like if you come to
Utah State University and you're like,
I don't have a major, um, they may
put you as undeclared, but they
may just leave it null in terms of
it's just empty. It doesn't mean
it's zero. It doesn't mean it's
not applicable. It's just empty. So
I'm missing a few different, a few
of them, a few of their labels.
But if I look here and I could
see here that I have, um,
two nulls. I also have a 26 orange,
uh, 22 pink, 33 red and 17 yellow.
So if you like red Starburst,
this is probably a good bag of
Starburst for you, right? My yellow
is not going to be too happy
about that. So just keep that. I
don't know why Starburst helped
me remember to group by, but if
you have an aggregated field and
a non-aggregated field, make sure
you group by the non-aggregated
field, okay? So I think about
that in terms of Starburst. So here
we have our Starburst laid out.
Again, if you have an aggregated
field and a non-aggregated field
in the select clause, group by
the non-aggregated field. Okay.
So another pop quiz, will this run?
Looking for average age and college
level in the employee table.
Will this run?
No, it will not run. I need to
group by age here. So after my from
clause, I may have a where clause,
I may not but after my from clause
I would say group by college to
make this run okay so that's all I
have for you on the group by we're
going to jump into having which is
really helpful as well in dealing
with our groups take care everybody